hey guys Pete here welcome to 2058 this
will be my Westworld season 3 episode 1
recap and review the episode is titled
parcei domine
after a religious hymn according to what
I found online it's a plea to an angry
God to spare their people in the episode
the lore says that the real gods are
here and they're very angry but before
we get into that this is your spoiler
warning this video will contain spoilers
for everything that's happened in West
world up to this point
go watch the episode first and then come
back here hit the subscribe button on
your way out though as I will be doing
Westworld videos throughout the season
the episode was directed by the show's
co-creator Jonathan Nolan who also wrote
the episode with his co-creator slash
wife Lisa joy as I mentioned at the
beginning we know for sure for the first
time that things are taking place in
2058 we're in the real world three
months after Dolores escaped from the
park in a host body that looked like
Charlotte Hale at the end of season 2 we
saw that Dolores had recreated a body
for herself but one of the five hosts
consciousnesses from the five pearls we
saw her smuggle out in her handbag into
that Hale body she was in and she also
recreated a new version of Bernard I'm
just gonna call him Bernard rather than
Arnold or Bernard old he's a little bit
of both but when she created in the
first time they called him Bernard and
it's just a bit easier for now those are
the familiar characters we know from the
park that are out in the real world
William aka the man in black also
survived season 2 but he doesn't show up
in this episode yet we have a new
setting and we also have a new major
character named Caleb as you probably
recognize as Aaron Paul who was in
Breaking Bad and he was voicing Bojack
horseman he's a soldier or a veteran of
some kind we see some flashbacks of him
and it's not exactly clear where he is
or what's going on with his military
service in the current timeline he is a
construction worker but he's trying to
improve himself in Caleb's world
everything is determined by algorithms
in the same way that we get ads when we
look at things online
you know Netflix tells us which show to
watch next and everything else that we
have in our 2020 things that basically
advanced we see these little animations
that show divergences and things in the
preseason when they announced the series
premiere date we had one of these
trailers and we learned that in 2039 the
first version of this was launched it's
been about 20 years now if you didn't
follow everything in the off season they
did a lot of promotion around this
company insight and basically what it
does is it takes all your data and then
it helps you to make the best decisions
at the same time they were developing
this there was also new laws that dealt
with data collection and things so
basically people sign up for this they
give over their information willingly
and then the software figures out what
they should do with their life there
also appears to be some kind of point
system which we here Caleb mentioned
several times that's supposed to operate
on a meritocracy but it seems like he's
stuck in a loop if you will stuck in a
dead-end job
it's got money problems because his
mother are sick so even though they're
supposed to be better living through
technology things don't seem all that
fantastic in order to make money on the
side he uses a crime app which I'm not
sure how I feel about I like the
world-building here for the most part I
guess this app though it just seems
strange to me that there's this
algorithmic system that knows everything
that everybody's doing or that what they
should do but yet this thing can just
exist I'm not sure if it's going to turn
out that they develop this as well
because they realize that crime is gonna
exist one way or the other so they might
as well manage that in a way as well or
if it's just a thing that hackers are
really good at hiding this kind of
activity we see some of his high jinks
doing some of these different jobs and
eventually that brings him in contact
with Dolores to me it seems most likely
that his character is there to show
Dolores a different side of humanity
she obviously dealt with these rich
people who came in and behaved badly
inside the park there's a lot of
callbacks to the early introduction of
Dolores when we see him like the way he
wakes up in bed and his life seems to be
a loop and there will be a
discussion about whether he's a host or
not but my point of view is that that is
not where they're headed with this
character like I said I think he's
probably going to be there to show her a
different side of humanity and what they
get into together we'll have to wait and
see either way I like seeing a new
character to give us an idea of how this
world works we see that he's going
through some therapy and that the actual
therapist doesn't have time to do talk
therapy so he ends up having these
conversations with his friend who he
lost in the war we get the impression
that it might be real but it seems
pretty obvious when they reveal that
it's AI that he's talking to and he ends
up unsubscribing he ends up quitting his
therapy and I think the big takeaway
from the whole thing was that it was
just trying to keep him in his loop
essentially you know I was trying to
keep him from going against the system
all of the therapy kind of with air
quotes was to keep him happy in his
lower station in life you know so he
does in fact run into Dolores at the end
of the episode you kind of have to feel
bad for him a little bit because he
wants to find somebody real after
talking to this AI and he runs into
Dolores who is of course a robot her
story picks up and we see that she's
still on the same kind of trajectory
she's at a rich man's house and she
takes him down after stealing his money
and getting some documents about insight
these documents may be how she found
Liam Dempsey who we learn is the son of
the founder of the insight system as we
get to know him we learn about Rehoboam
and we see as a giant device we also
learned that he isn't really in control
of it that is somebody else named CEREC
who I'm guessing is the character that
vincent cassell played before she can
get that information out Liam herself
his bodyguard
figures out that she's not who she says
she was he steps in and he's going to
get rid of her
Liam doesn't put up much of a fight and
whenever it comes to that he doesn't
seem that concerned a problem comes up
and that she's not human so when he
tries to poison her it doesn't have any
effect she's able to get away and we
learned that it was all part of her plan
when she already has a duplicate of
this has another one of the pearls
inside of it from the park we don't know
which one but she takes out the original
the host version takes his place and
she'll still have access to Liam plus
she now knows that this person Ciroc who
we haven't met yet is the real power
behind everything so I mentioned that
Dolores rebuilt Bernard he's somewhere
far from where we've seen Dolores I
believe he's in the Philippines it's in
Asia but they speak Mandarin when he
gets to where he's going and I'm not
sure how important that is since it is
actually 2058 he works in a meat plant
he's trying to keep a low profile
somebody finds him his co-workers he
ends up beating them down he ends up
escaping we see that he is running
self-analysis trying to make sure that
Dolores hasn't taken over that no one's
been getting into his code he's got this
little fob that he carries around so
that he can go out of like nice guy
Bernard mode into Terminator mode I
guess either way he gets out of the meat
packing business and he heads back to
West World he charters a boat and that's
where his story leaves off the other
character that we have is the Charlotte
Hale body
we don't know who's inside but she's
able to pass the Charlotte she's able to
get into the meeting at Delos we find
out that part of Dolores is planned and
bringing back Bernard is to make him the
scapegoat for what happened at West
world essentially Charlotte tells the
board everything that went wrong there
was because of him not because of
Dolores takes the heat off of her and in
the board room meeting we see that there
is an empty chair that would be for
William as far as we know she wants to
keep the park open well the other member
says well you can't do that without
William and they're able to use this
algorithm to say that he would actually
agree with her so it's okay and they're
going to move ahead in the post-credits
scene we see that Maeve has been brought
back after being killed remember some of
the hosts went through to the valley
beyond to the sublime and
there's were killed Hector armistice and
mave were all killed but her daughter
made it through Akita they made it
through and Teddy was sent there later
she's now in World War two world or war
world which is in Europe during the
years of World War two as far as we can
tell we saw quite a few shots of this
from trailers so she'll be there at
least for the next episode or so the
scene makes it look like she just woke
up but at the same time we see that her
knuckles are beat up and that she's
actually been there already not exactly
sure what's going on there it's more of
a tease than anything else but we know
Bernard is going back to the part we
know that Maeve is in the park and based
on what we saw Hale doing we have to
imagine that things will go back to
normal at least in part of the parks I'm
not sure that West's world will be open
anytime soon but see that at least some
of it is so that's mostly what happened
it's a pretty straightforward episode
not very confusing which should be good
news to some people it's a bit early to
say I mean they're starting over it's
almost a reboot so I like the
world-building for the most part I'm
excited to see where things go it feels
like the mystery is gonna be one who are
the pearls that she brought with her and
then to what is her actual plan that
there has to be a bigger picture plan
that Dolores is gonna develop here in
her time destroying all humans doesn't
seem like that would make for a very
satisfying conclusion for the series and
so where will she end up what will she
end up wanting to do I like the idea
behind the algorithmic determination I
like the idea of freewill and what does
that actually mean there's a lot of
potential there but we'll have to see
where they go things looked great the
acting was up to the normal level where
we're used to seeing which is always
pretty good music was good so it's a
pretty solid start I'm interested to see
what you think let me know in the
comments what do you think's going on
with insight what do you think's going
on in the park and most importantly
who's inside Hales body which host
consciousness is inside there and what
is Dolores planning to do now that she's
got some momentum
side in our world let me know what you
think please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'll be
covering Westworld throughout the rest
of the season
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon